hey guys how's it going today I've got
some special guests in my house hi I'm
Bailey and this is my sister Jenna I'm
usually here I'm not really a special
guest Wow I thought it'd be so fun to do
a sister versus sister challenge of
playing pictionary but it took us a
really long time to try to figure out
how we wanted to actually set this up me
built that easel we did we did a really
fun video on their channel it was an
emoji charades challenge yeah it was so
crazy
oh you guys need to go check it out it's
on their channel I'll put links in the
description and up there on the eye and
make sure you guys subscribe because
they're absolutely amazing this is gonna
be so fun so here's the rules we don't
really know what the rules are make them
up as we go and we think this is how
we're gonna play we're all going to be
drawing something so for example you
guys will pick a card they may be there
with the card and then we will draw it
and then our teammates sister will have
to try to guess whoever gets the most
points at the end when we decide the
game is over that's the winner we have a
time limit right we do it whether it's
right in 60 seconds for you to draw as
many of these on our singular card as we
can and while our sister tries together
I know I am NOT the most artistic um I
can't even draw a figure so I'm not so
are all in trouble we all should be
doing oh well here we go wishes luck
okay first up let's figure cards ready
first are you ready
[Applause]
diving pool diving boards your water
bubbles back bubble about deaf person
spit water back floaties
[Applause]
[Music]
Apple oh well that was that flower pot
plant mace finger-pointing don't get one
is there more let's - player it's
kicking tweet what is that this would be
the graph if you wrote you know right
your giant squiggly lines on arrow
distantly marker all over your face
you're full 15-15-15
when we have six all right well let's go
here we go again
good teeth - better teeth spider veins
my leg
eyepatch black widow spider you could
show up here I'm taking the point out
week two points we don't do so well sir
persons oh wait you tasted it meat bacon
you lift your clothes when you're going
to put them away hold them I'm absolute
trash is the pig where that was a dog
and he was sitting okay that was
different woman one I was trying to stop
it look at this I am crying in my own
paper
alarm for all over water what has
happened to me sister switch all right
me and Jenna are trash we're doing a
sister switch basically we're switching
sisters so it's better on a team and me
Justine are a team and we're gonna
hopefully redeem their status a little
safe I like this circle
Oh angry crowd applause what a treat
[Applause]
[Music]
okay no Mazen magic so far I like me the
weakest life now on to a really horrible
this game do we what are we doing ah I
don't know
the time is go sky circle Sun sunrise
and sunset bazooka balloons
basketball football field
okay the times up so it looks like me
and judge Darren we lost an awful I
already know I'm very good job I'm crash
that's it thanks so much for watching so
the score was what I don't want to say
it was 25 but that's terrible weird I
told you I'm not good with you tonight
this year's well sister of our sister
but we're going to need to do a
Redemption if you guys want to see how
to try something else leave us some more
sister versus sister comments in the
comments below
but you must go check out their channel
we did a super fun video it was emoji
charades you guys definitely check it
out it was crazy too it's yeah okay you
got intense yet they're trying
be sure to see cry I did cry but I'm not
to watch and find out what happened if I
don't have any gifts for you guys oh you
shall give them pictionary so that I
never call we can wanted 100 legendary
game you enjoy those congratulations
cookie and me lost get out of here there
this is accurate for how I feel well
thank you guys again and make sure you
check out their channel and go subscribe
I'll put all the links in the
description and at the end cards and
we'll see you guys later
yeah I hate pictionary ohh
[Music]
you